♪ (SOMBER MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
AMANDA MUSTARD:
I love...
that I get to make exposing
the truth about something
a part of my job.
♪ (LIVELY MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
I had this new language
to describe things that
for my whole life
I thought were just normal.
Like the way that some men
treated me and my body,
that was actually assault.
Or my touchy, feely grandpa
is actually a pedophile.
♪ (TENSE MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
When I watch these tapes,
I see a man
with a serious problem
who knows that
he's not gonna get caught.
Was there anybody
that you ever felt
like you could talk to about it?
(SIGHS)
♪ (SOMBER MUSIC RESUMES) ♪
AMANDA: Do you feel like
God has forgiven you?
Absolutely.
It's hard to forgive someone
who doesn't ask for forgiveness.
SPEAKER:
My stuff I went through,
it's never as big as
what you've had to go through.
AMANDA'S MOTHER:
Of course I feel responsible.
She's my kid, and I've always
wanted to protect her.
If you stay angry
and can't forgive somebody,
you're drinking the poison
yourself.
You've got to let go.
I would like to not have
my relationship with my mom end.
"I'm writing to you
as you may have been
a past patient
of William Flickinger,
and I'm in the process
of taking accountability
for my grandfather's actions."
If I can be the one
to step forward
and on the record, say,
"He did this.
You can't deny it,"
it's the very least
that I can do.
♪ (MUSIC CONCLUDES) ♪